mesdames et messieurs mes chers amis
monsieur le secrétaire général chez éric
g de participer à la rédaction de
nombreux projets politiques qui avaient
la caractéristique de se terminer par
qu'est ce qu'on dit sur la culture et
qu'est ce qu'on dit sur le sport et en
général on disait pas grand chose nous
avons voulu avec eric avec david et qui
inverser les choses
la culture est la réponse à la crise à
la crise d'identité et aussi à la crise
économique
et c'est une première idée importante
pour nous monsieur le président nous
n'avons aucun complexe à évoquer la
culture dans une dimension économique la
culture dans une dimension culturelle
naturellement mais ça ne rend pas
illégitime
le projet culturel le projet artistique
que de dire que la culture est une
industrie de pointe pour l'économie
française
le pays qui reçoit le plus de touristes
au monde doit considérer la culture
comme un atout économique essentiel donc
c'est la culture pour nous est une
réponse à la crise d'identité
nous ne voulons pas d'un monde aplati
nous ne voulons pas d'un monde où n'y
aurait qu'une culture et qu'une langue
nous respectons les identités de toutes
les cultures à travers le monde
mais nous disons fermement il n'est pas
question pour nous qu'on brade notre
langue notre patrimoine
le spectacle vivant chez nous est ce que
nous ont transmis ceux qui nous ont
précédés il y a un patrimoine culturel
français qui est notre référence qui
sont nos racines que nous voulons
embellir agrandir dont nous voulons nous
mêmes à notre tour le transmettre à nos
enfants et ça n'empêche en rien de
reconnaître de saluer la dimension
économique
quand nous avons supprimé un tiers des
emplois militaires à metz tout le monde
m'a demandé une administration et la
réponse sur une idée qui pucelle
d'aillagon qui n'a pas eu que des
mauvaises idées qu'il n'appelle que des
bonnes non plus notamment son soutien
françois blanc connaissez cette phrase
la maladie cette maladie des chiens non
transmissible à l'homme
la fidélité cette maladie les chiens non
enfin bon mais l'idée de beaubourg à
metz c'était une bonne idée est en
pleine crise avec eric woerth
nous avons protégé les crédits n'est ce
pas pour que beaubourg messe puisse
ouvrir la première année un million de
visiteurs la réponse pour le devenir du
département et de la ville de metz
c'était pas une administration de plus
c'était pas des bases dont nous n'avons
plus besoin de nous n'avions plus besoin
du fait de la suppression du service
national
c'est être une réponse culturelle j'ai
vu que monsieur hollande avec grand
plaisir avait inauguré le louvre à lens
et oublié de l'inviter
mais il n'a pas lu si classique un seul
être vous manque et tout est dépeuplé
mais visiblement je ne vais pas me
manquer mais il n'en reste pas moins que
le financement et la décision de faire
le louvre le louvre à lens
c'est une décision que nous avions prise
parce que lens qui a connu tant temps de
crise le textile mines la sidérurgie eh
bien il ya les sang et or l'équipe de
football
et désormais il ya le lourd équipe
contester que le louvre de lens sera une
réponse économique à la désespérance
économique d'une région
de la même façon j'ai voulu en pleine
crise des spas eric philharmonique à
paris parce que je ne supporte plus
david l'idée que le monde entier se
couvre de grues que les plus grands
architectes travaillent partout dans le
monde et que chez nous le seul groupe
qui existe dans la capitale c'est celle
des équipements que nous avions décidé
et lorsqu'il a fallu trancher y compris
contre ceux qui avaient moins d'ambition
sur france je les fais dans mon
gouvernement y compris à matignon pour
imposer ses équipements culturels
naturellement qu'à l'époque
et pour ceux qui ont vu la magnifique
série vers ça ils s'en souviennent
lorsque louis xiv a voulu versailles
il ya beaucoup de gens aujourd'hui on
n'a pas les moyens il va ruiner la
france avec 7 millions de visiteurs
chaque année depuis tant d'années
versailles c'est une richesse ou c'est
un problème donc la culture pour nous
les républicains est au coeur de notre
projet ils structurent notre projet
ayant sa david une autre question
une autre raison pendant des décennies
la culture a été soi disant le monopole
de la gauche
et tout le monde n'a pas le courage de
benoît solès parce qu'il en faut
doit être un artiste comme lui et
s'afficher il ya tellement d'hypocrisie
il ya tellement le souci de l'image et
je dois rendre hommage à monsieur
hollande qui nous a rendu un service
considérable il a tellement massacrer le
budget culturel et la culture dans ce
pays que enfin les intervenants
culturels honnêtes ont compris qu'il
fallait discuter avec nous parce que
l'avenir d'une politique culturelle
ambitieuse en france elle passe par la
droite
elle ne passe plus par la gauche il
avait promis de doubler le budget il
voulait ça brille c'est la vérité je
suis tout à fait prêt à parler du budget
de la culture
lorsque j'étais président la république
qui n'a fait l'objet d'aucune polémique
parce que j'ai toujours veillé à
préserver le budget de la culture
car si on ne préserve pas le budget de
la culture
c'est qu'on est un fidèle à l'héritage
que l'on a reçue et vous savez pour moi
ça a beaucoup compté y compris et
notamment pour le patrimoine de voir ce
que les années berlusconi avait fait en
italie ce pays frère
ce pays tellement riche d'un patrimoine
exceptionnel regarder l'état du
patrimoine italien
je ne critique personne et regardez
l'état du patrimoine français église
cathédrale musées monuments ou des
efforts considérables ont été engagés
ça n'a pas été fait chez notre voisin
s'équiper chez nous comment porter
l'idée d'une identité française vivante
et ne pas entretenir un patrimoine que
nous avons reçu en héritage
ça n'aurait tout simplement aucun sens
david donc raison il faut protéger les
dispositifs fiscaux qui permettent
d'entretien patrimoine et ce patrimoine
génère des recettes économiques dont
tant de villes dans deux villages dans
mon droit ont besoin dans le monde
la deuxième idée que je voulais défendre
devant vous et qui est spécifique aux
républicains david emmanuel david hervé
c'est que pour vivre un être humain a
besoin de se nourrir de boire et de se
cultiver
nous sommes sans doute dans le vivant la
seule espèce dont le besoin de culture
est identitaire il ya quarante mille ans
il peignait à lascaux il ya trente-six
mille ans il peignait à chauray qu'elle
est l'espèce du vivant
via ce rapport identitaire avec la
création la création artistique n'est
pas un choix c'est une identité pour
l'être humain qui a besoin pour lutter
contre la mort pour se poursuivre pour
s'inscrire dans une forme d'éternité de
peindre de dessiner de jouer de la
musique ou d'écrire ce n'est pas un
choix c'est une identité
à ma connaissance sotheby's n'existait
pas au moment de la grotte de lascaux ou
au moment de jouer et les premiers
hommes qui ont eu conscience de leur
destin singulier ont éprouvé le besoin
de conceptualiser non pas ce qu'il
voyait
mais la façon dont ils le voyaient la
modernité de tous ces dessins est
exceptionnel et montre bien que la
culture n'est pas un choix pour l'homme
c'est une façon de vivre l'homme a
besoin de boire de se nourrir et de se
cultiver et c'est ce qui fait la
spécificité du message culturel de la
france tout le monde ne pense pas cela
nous pensons cela et qu'on ne vienne pas
me dire que la tranche de jambon est
normal pour un taux de réduit de tva
mais que le livre c'est normal qui n'est
pas un taux réduit
parce que si l'on considère que la
culture est un élément essentiel de l'x
distance de l'être humain de façon
identitaire à l'on doit considérer que
le combat pour une tva à taux réduit
pour les produits culturels
c'est un combat vital parce que les
produits culturels dans la conception de
la politique culturelle des républicains
ce sont des biens de première nécessité
il ne s'agit pas il ne s'agit pas et on
en a parlé et il ne s'agit pas de faire
un cadeau à qui que ce soit ça n'a
absolument aucun sens
il s'agit d'être cohérent avec notre
rapport à la culture
si notre rapport à la culture et
identitaire alors on considère que le
produit culturel
c'est un produit de première nécessité
si on considère que la culture est un
domaine d'un projet économique comme les
autres alors on n'a pas à se faire de
soucis et d'ailleurs je n'accepte même
pas l'argument budgétaire parce que
comme on a vu disparaître tous les
disquaires de nos villes comme l'objet
physique a disparu malheureusement et
j'espère qu'il reviendra en tout cas sur
la forme du vinyle puisque je suis
persuadé qu'il rend toujours un public
un marché des gens qui voudront
conserver l'objet qui sont attachés
comme moi l'objet qu'on ne lira pas tous
des livres numériques sur le numérique
que un certain nombre d'entre nous pas
simplement les vieux sont attachés à
l'objet quand il m
1 cd yves le garder quand ils apprécient
un livre ils veulent le prêter ou leur
donner à ses enfants ou quand il aime un
film ils veulent le garder chez eux tout
n'est pas dans le jeu table tout n'est
pas dans l'accessoire tous les pas dans
la piètre qualité
il ya aussi des gens qui aiment le pot
et c'est pas parce que le bo est
subjectif qui n'existe pas voilà je sais
dit je reconnais que c'est pas tout à
fait dans le sujet mais c'est
profondément ce que je pense quand on
aime une oeuvre
on aime la posséder ne non pas du tout
pour la garder jalousement
mais au contraire pour faire quelque
chose qui est essentiel dans la culture
pour partager les meilleurs amis on ne
partage pas ce qu'on n'a pas donc je
sais c'est très compliqué ce que je dis
mais je le pense très profondément
c'est assez compliqué de partager
l'identité qu'on refuse ou de partager
un dvd un disque cd ou même 1
vivre as tu lu ce livre je vais te tiens
je te le bret
voilà je ne me rends pas étranger aux
nouvelles technologies mais je veux dire
que le choix c'est cela et donc je
considère pour ma part que le la
question du tarif réduit de tva pour les
biens culturels est une question
centrale qui se rattache aux messages 2
de la france et quand quand on voit le
nombre de ses déguisements
ça va pas être très cher mais c'est
essentiel et que dire de la différence
de pba entre le numérique et le physique
sur les biens culturels jal avait tu
t'en souviens cher eric résolu et
tranché malgré ou en dépit des objets
ration de la commission européenne
j'avais eu à l'époque circonstances un
dialogue
comment dit-on francs avec monsieur
barroso qui m'avait dit man x nicolas
comment peux-tu considérer de mettre le
livre au même niveau que les tranches de
jambon c'est lui qui avait pris
l'exemple du 10 mai toi tu es bien
portugais au portugal pas est immense
s'appelle pessoa est un homme qui vient
du portugal peut me dire que la culture
c'est pas identitaire c'est pas vital
pour un être humain
eh bien nous c'est ce qu'on pense en
france j'ai pas si au portugal vous le
pensez plus enfin portugal pays de
tradition culturelle comme cela vous
devriez le penser parce que sinon on
aura plus qu'une seule culture une seule
langue et que tous les films américains
que j'adore 1 comme vous mais qui
s'amortissent sur le marché américain et
qui arrivent en france qui cassent les
prix
et dans ce cas-là n'y aura plus qu'un
seul cinéma au monde une seule musique
au monde une seule langue au monde et le
monde sera aplati la france la france
éternelle ne veut pas de l'aplatissement
du monde
c'est là que cette proposition
nous faisons à partir de ce moment là il
ya bien d'autres choses parmi les autres
choses hier fameuse opposition entre le
patrimoine et spectacle vivant
je voudrais dire un mot parce que c'est
tellement ridicule le patrimoine c'est
le spectacle vivant d'hyères molière et
racines ont été le spectacle vivant
corneille a bien été troublé par
l'arrivée de ce jeune ambitieux avec
phèdre à l'époque parce que ça n'a pas
été facile de pour corneille de vivre la
concurrence effrénée de racine
ils ont été le spectacle vivante de leur
époque qui sont devenues notre
patrimoine et donc pour moi il ya un
continuum
nous devons respecter le patrimoine nous
devons l'entretenir
c'est pourquoi nous proposons la
création d'une fondation pour le
patrimoine qui permettent de mobiliser
des crédits importants venant du privé
pour nous aider à entretenir notre
patrimoine et je ne vois pas pourquoi on
devrait se boucher le nez parce que
c'est les crédits qu'ils viennent du
privé
les maires cher david se bat avec
tellement de force pour trouver des
crédits
on doit favoriser le sponsoring le
partenariat la possibilité d'obtenir du
crédit qui s'investissent dans notre
culture
tant mieux les mairies sont tellement
importantes pour financer la politique
culturelle et je pense exactement la
même chose pour le spectacle vivant
je veux d'ailleurs m'inscris en faux
contre ceux qui disent qu'il ya eu trop
de films l'année dernière près de 200 je
comprends qu'on puisse dire que c'est
trop mais je préfère le troc l'eau trop
peu et à ceux qui me disent c'est trop
comment limites et qui aura le droit et
comment on maintient le statut français
de grande nation cinématographique
le cnc pour moi un exemple de ce qu'il
convient de faire et j'ai toujours
veillé à préserver les crédits du cng
parce que le cinéma dans dans l'histoire
d'un pays c'est absolument considérable
et nous devons rester une grande nation
cinématographique
nous sommes les héritiers d'un passé en
la matière glorieux et bientôt nous
rang et le cnc est pour moi un exemple
je voudrais d'ailleurs que la musique se
dote du même système et je me demande
encore pourquoi monsieur hollande a
cassé le centre de la musique que nous
avions prévu d'organiser alors que la
musique est dans une telle situation
dans notre pays
je dis à tous les professionnels de la
musique que nous ferons ce sens et que
nous prélèverons sur un certain nombre
de fournisseurs d'accès ya de la marge
il ya de la marge oui il ya de la marge
et d'ailleurs je souhaite que l'on
réfléchisse aux contrats qui ont été
négociées entre un certain nombre de
majeurs et ses fournisseurs d'accès pour
la musique parce que c'est un paradoxe
il n'y a jamais eu autant besoin de
musique dans le monde on n'a jamais
utilisé autant de visites et jamais
l'industrie de la musique s'est trouvé
en une situation aussi difficile
il ya quand même une raison et nous
n'avons pas l'intention de céder là
dessus pas davantage que nous voulons
céder sur les quotas et que les choses
soient claires entre nous je suis pour
la liberté mais des obligations de
production en langue française avec des
auteurs français et de diffusion de
séries françaises
deux films français ça ne me choque pas
bien au contraire
ou alors simplement va continuer on a
déjà une harmonisation dramatique des
programmes de la télévision n'y a jamais
eu autant de chaînes et aux jamais aussi
peu de choix
c'est un avis personnel mais je veux
quand même dire que l'hyper concurrence
tu la diversité et pour ceux qui sont
des as peur fou ça peut m'arriver aussi
surtout depuis que maintenant on n'a pas
à se lever
moi j'ai connu ça quand même donc ça
limite est l'ambition de ce changement
de programme on était plus fidèles à
l'époque de qu'on était plus fainéants
fallait se lever
bon maintenant c'est plus du tout pareil
et bien quand vous happer 150 chaînes et
qu'est ce que vous voyez
absolument le même programme recyclé
comme si d'ailleurs alors dans deux
côtés des de la 150e vous avez une
chaîne de musique qui sert de prétexte
bas il n'y a pas besoin d'avoir de la
musique sur les grandes chaînes puisque
vous avez à 154 vous pouvez trouver à 3
heures du matin quelque chose à vous
mettre dans l'oreille ce n'est pas la
conception
nous avons le la production culturelle
et la diffusion culturelle française ne
me choque pas bien au contraire je crois
les communes marché mais alors pour le
coup je crois la dimension économique
des projets mais je pense que en la
matière plus encore quand d'autres je
crois la politique de l'offre parce que
c'est parce que vous offrez quelque
chose de qualité que vous rencontrez un
public
je pense que c'est très important ce qui
m'amènera à vous dire un mot de
l'audiovisuel public
bon je veux pas être cruel parce que ça
ne sert à rien et je ne veux me fâcher
avec personne mais enfin il faut quand
même dire deux trois choses qui est
capable aujourd'hui de voir la
différence entre un programme du public
et du privé
la réponse est éloquente vous l'avez dit
d'ailleurs la réponse est éloquente
je crois qu'il ya une raison il faut
qu'on s'empare très clairement si vous
continuez à financer le service public
avec de la redevance et avec de la
publicité
vous mettez sur la tyrannie de l'audimat
parce que si l'audimat baisse les
recettes de publicité baisse et à ce
moment là vous vous trouvez dans la
situation d'avoir les mêmes programmes
sur le public sur le privé
c'est pourquoi j'avais voulu limites
et je continue à penser que c'était une
bonne idée la publicité sur le service
public je les fais non pas pour des
raisons économiques
non pas pour des raisons morales mais
parce que je voulais des séries david
l'étreinte de l'audimat sur le service
public pour qu'enfin on ait des
émissions qui nous permette enfin de
dire aux téléspectateurs voilà vous
payer certains redevances mais enfin
vous savez des programmes comme on
devine que vous le verrez nulle part
ailleurs
parce que quelle est la légitimité de la
redevance si vous avez sur le service
public
les mêmes programmes que sur le service
privé donc je crois aux services publics
je crois à sa mission particulière je
crois qu'il doit être financée par la
redevance en tout cas pour l'essentiel
mais ça ne passe que par une seule chose
la légitimité du service public
c'est un programme différencié et une
déconnexion de l'audimat ça veut pas
dire que je veux personne regarde et
c'est très intéressant d'ailleurs quand
on voit le travail remarquable de
véronique cayla sur eux harper que d'un
travail dont je veux dire que pour moi
assez remarquable notamment dans sa
politique de diffusion cinématographique
il ya tellement de chefs-d'oeuvre qui
sont libres de droits il savait quand
même plaisir quand on vois tu vas sur
arte on a des films différents qu'on ne
voit pas ailleurs et ça justifie
l'existence en indépendamment des
relations avec nos amis allemands d'arte
et je veux dire également que le
spectacle auquel ont assisté lors de la
dernière nomination indépendante
heureusement que c'est préciser parce
que
qu'est ce que ça aurait été si ça
n'avait pas été indépendant pour moi
c'est clair la légitimité de la
nomination des présidents
d'établissement public de l'audiovisuel
public devraient être les commissions
spécialisées de l'assemblée nationale et
du sénat
je veux dire les commissions culturelles
à la majorité qualifiée pour être sûr
que majorité et opposition soient
obligés de se mettre d'accord en toute
transparence
parce que quand même le spectacle qu'a
donnée le csat d'un spectacle étonnant
d'audition secrète
donc on sait pas qui décide on sait pas
pourquoi il décide on sait pas qui a
candidaté on nous annonce simplement un
jour qu'il ya quelqu'un qui est sorti du
chapeau
c'est ça la démocratie
j'ajoute que toutes ces profusion
d'organismes prétendument indépendant
dont la dépendance reste à démontrer un
au moins par les commissions la
commission des affaires culturelles de
l'assemblée celle du sénat ça me
semblait manuel redonner d'abord de la
force aux élus et avec la majorité
qualifiée ainsi il n'y aurait pas de
problème je veux dire un mot de notre
rapport au droit et à la création
que les choses soient claires entre nous
jamais je ne céderai sur cette idée
essentielle à mes yeux que le droit
d'auteur
c'est une invention française etc avant
monsieur bon marché il y avait des
artistes qui étaient des esclaves de qui
des puissants et quand il ne plaisait
plus aux puissants ils été mis dehors
les plus grands ont connu cette
situation
mozart et les droits d'auteur
les droits d'auteur ça a donné la
liberté aux artistes parce que l'artiste
qui est propriétaire de son oeuvre peut
vivre de son oeuvre et refuser les
droits d'auteur c'est accepter l'idée du
vol et c'est accepter l'idée de
l'asservissement des artistes et de la
création
parce que naturellement quand on peut
pas vivre de son oeuvre on est dépendant
donc je crois aux droits d'auteur je
n'aime pas la culture du tout gratuit
je veux dire que républicains
considèrent que ce qu'on ne paye pas ne
respecte pas et le tout gratuit c est
exactement aussi désastreux que
d'expliquer à nos enfants qu'on peut
tout avoir sans effort le gratuit
c'est la culture du refus de l'effort
nous sommes pour l'effort
nous sommes pour le mérite nous sommes
pour le travail nous sommes pour l'année
rtd artistes nous sommes pour les droits
d'auteur et leur respect voilà ça coince
ici quelqu'un compris quelque chose à ce
que le rapport de monsieur lescure sur
hadopi
si vous êtes drôlement fort parce que
moi j'ai vu un tour de passe passe assez
misérable qui a démoli l'efficacité
d'hadopi sans oser affronter les
artistes parce que l'hypocrisie règne en
maîtresse absolue
donc moi je ne suis pas attaché david
eric hadopi dans sa forme initiale
je suis attachée au principe du respect
des droits d'auteur je pense que quand
on pille une oeuvre
c'est du vol et qui donc qu'il faut qui
est un système de sanctions david
bien sûr qu'il faut un lieu depuis deux
ans un hadopi 3 en 2004 mais je ne vois
pas pourquoi on accepterait les sites de
screamin illégal qui vivent sur les
offres des auteurs qui pillent qui ne
paye pas ce qu'ils vendent mais qui se
font payer avec ce qu'ils vendent parce
que l'idée dira oui mais vous savez il
est très généreux en mai la disposition
gratuitement c'est gratuit pour qui sauf
pour eux qu'ils se font rémunérer
c'est à dire que quand je prends je
prends gratuitement quand je vends je
vends pas gratuitement c'est logique ça
on doit l'accepter cela dans la vérité
c'est que c'est il ya une forme de
jaunissement dire ouh là là on va semer
man avec les jeunes alors silence dans
les rangs pourquoi parce que les jeunes
sont pas capables de comprendre ça les
jeux ne sont pas capables de comprendre
que s'il n'y a pas de droit d'auteur y
aura plus de créations demain pour les
jeunes eux mêmes parce que les stars le
second pas un patrimoine à un catalogue
cela ils s'en sortiront toujours mais
les jeunes comment il s'en tient alors
naturellement david moi je suis pour la
liberté
si un artiste veut être diffusée
gratuitement c'est son choix mais ça
doit pas lui être imposée ça ne doit pas
dû être imposé
et je crois
la puissance d'internet bien sûr je
crois que c'est un progrès fantastique
mais c'est pas parce que c'est internet
qui aurait pu y avoir aucune règle les
règles des droits d'auteur la règle
essentielle à mes yeux du droit à
l'oubli
le droit à l'oubli c'est quelque chose
de considérable
vous comprenez quand vous avez 70 ans et
quand google is sa personnalité
ressource que vous avez fait à 17 ans le
droit à l'oubli c'était quelque chose de
très important pour l'équilibré d'une
société
excusez moi ce sont des principes qui
compte dans un état de droit on ne peut
pas considérer que ça n'existe pas comme
des progrès ont été faits dans la lutte
contre le terroriste comme des progrès
ont été faits dans la lutte contre la
pédophilie
je voudrais dire que internet ce progrès
fantastique ça n'implique pas pour nous
de renoncer à des principes qui sont les
principes d'une société civilisée
enfin le problème des intermittents du
spectacle je veux dire
évidemment certains monde il faut pas en
parler
oui bien sûr on parle de rien on ment
sur tout et après on se retrouve dans la
situation de françois hollande
bon ce qui n'est pas notre objectif du
tout je veux redire notre attachement au
principe d'un statut des intermittents
du spectacle et je ne veux pas qu'il y
ait d'ambiguïté là dessus je le dis
chiche prêts à le défendre gelé défendu
devant mes amis et rythme en porter
témoignage pourquoi parce que les
entreprises culturelles ne sont pas des
entreprises tout à fait comme les autres
d'abord il ya une intermittence de
l'activité on ne passe pas d'un film un
autre sauf contretemps et woody allen
mais enfin quand même là on mêle assez
haut le niveau qui est infime part enfin
hitchcock en fait un homme faisait un
tous les quatre ans et donc il ya une
intermittence de la création qui
justifie parfaitement le statut
d'intermittent du spectacle et donc ait
pas d'ambiguïté entre entre nous le
statut des intermittents
c'est
spécifiques nous voulons le conserver
parce que s'il n'avait pas ce statut
il ya beaucoup d'entreprises culturelles
qui ne survivrait pas c'est vrai ce que
je dis et je suis désolé moi je ne suis
pas dans un raisonnement
comment vous dire idiot logique clanique
au nom du libéralisme ceci ou de cela je
crois que c'est utile en revanche un
milliard d'euros ça n'a pas de sens il
ya des fraudes et tout le monde le sait
bien je ne suis pas sûr que le statut
des intermittents du spectacle était
fait pour compenser le manque de
personnel de france télévisions je me
noie je ne suis pas content non plus
absolument que france télévision je ne
dis pas de force des visions ne doit pas
pour telle ou telle activité utiliser un
statut mais enfin il ya des excès il ya
des abus et on ne peut pas vouloir être
artiste avec eux l'adrénaline de
l'artiste et avoir un statut de
fonctionnaire avec l'adrénaline du
statut de fonctionnaire
ce que j'ai voulu dire c'est ma
contribution à la pensée unique et pour
être sûr je suis bien politique voilà
donc on peut pas avoir les deux mais il
me semble alors on va y travailler un
david sur les pistes de réforme du
statut des intermittents
on garde le principe on garde un statut
dérogatoire mais nous voulons par
respect pour l'importance de ce statut
dérogatoire
nous voulons lutter contre les fraudes
et mettre un terme à certaines
situations absurdes et d'ailleurs je
veux le dire c'est pas une bonne
mécanique que celle qui consiste par une
minorité à dire si vous touchez à mon
statut je ruine tous les festivals sarah
écoutez moi ça me plaît pas on discute
pas comme ça en france on ne prend pas
en otage des milliers des milliers de
bénévoles qui font vivre des festivals
l'été fantastique
on doit pouvoir se mettre autour d'une
table discuter sérieusement et trouver
les solutions
la prise d'otages mais en risquant péril
le statut alors et pour vraiment porter
minés un mot sur les structures la
question de la culture éducation
nationale et la question du ministère de
la culture
d'abord après y avoir bien réfléchi fois
ministre de la culture c'est sûr enfin
le ministre de la culture il faut qu'il
soit très près du président de la
république parce que le protecteur des
arts c'est président de république parce
que c'est pas le ministre de la culture
et son budget qui peuvent décider de
moyens pour des gestes culturel
important
on a souvent dit monsieur lang avait un
pommier culture ce qui est vrai mais il
a été
parce que monsieur mitterrand est
derrière lui et le ministre la culture
doit pouvoir être très proche du
président d'un public mais il faut
changer la structure du ministère de la
culture on ne peut pas continuer comme
ça parce qu'au ministère de la culture
aujourd'hui ignore la réalité du poids
des collectivités territoriales et je
préfèrerait de beaucoup un ministère qui
serait organisée autour d'objectifs la
danse la musique le livre plutôt qu'en
multiples bureaux dont plus personne de
comprendre comment ça fonctionne avec
des ramifications territoriale
extravagantes qui sont devenus
extravagantes par le nombre et qui n'ont
plus un sou à distribuer ses airs qu'on
fait semblant qui encore des subventions
à distribuer il y en a plus on a gardé
la structure qui distribuait contrôler
ces subventions
il y en a plus mais les structures
existent ne distribuent plus plus rien
et on doit me semble-t-il repenser le
ministère la culture autour de l'idée
des missions des objectifs et des
grandes disciplines voyez moi je crois à
la nécessité d'un ministère important
faut-il rapprocher 2006 à la culture
d'éducation nationale je réfléchis aussi
je n'y crois pas je vois bien
l'inspiration
si on admet mme maëlys culture éducation
nationale on va faire entrer la culture
d'éducation nationale la vérité c'est
que ça ne marche pas c'est un peu de
noix de gresham à l'envers pourquoi la
loi de gresham c'est la mauvaise monnaie
chasse la bonne
mais là c'est le gros ministères qui
chasse le petit celui qui est ou celle
des ministres de la culture ministre de
l'éducation il est d'abord ministres
éducation parce qu'il a géré un million
de personnes
il sera jamais d'abord ministre de la
culture et donc on est obligé de nommer
un secrétaire d'état
secrétaires d'état qui a encore moins de
pouvoir et qui vient se trouvait écrasé
par la structure d'éducation nationale
alors ça ne veut pas dire bien au
contraire qu'il faut pas développer le
temps scolaire pour la culture et le
temps périscolaire je devrais dire un
mot là-dessus le temps scolaire pour la
culture j'aimerais tellement essaie de
convaincre qu'il ne s'agit pas de faire
ânonner 4,5 cours de solfège à des
enfants qui ne leur ont jamais d'un
instrument de musique pour moi
l'ambition de l'enseignement artistique
à l'école c'est l'ambition de donner
envie de partager une émotion artistique
pas de donner le sentiment à chacun qui
s'est dessinée qui connaît le solfège je
préférais de beaucoup que tous les
enfants qui sortent du collège du lycée
et l' envie d'aller au théâtre et envies
regarder un film ait envie d'écouter de
la musique plutôt qu'il se soit ennuyeux
à mourir dans des classes de solfège qui
ne serviront à rien ou dans des classes
de dessin au pardon quand on était aussi
peu de l ue - même avec les meilleurs
professeurs la perspective c'est pas un
truc qu'on a spontanément en soi donc
content mais je veux pas porter atteinte
à qui que ce soit un jeu dit que
l'objectif politique culturelle scolaire
c'est de faire partager des émotions
artistiques et là c'est fantastique
parce qu'à ce moment où l'émotion
artistique a fait naître dans l'enfant
un besoin il ya tout le temps
périscolaire qui peut être florence avec
les collectivités territoriales
un moment d'approfondissement pour les
enfants qui sont plus doués qui ont plus
d'appétence ou cliente envie d'aller
plus loin
l'école doit apprendre le partage de
l'émotion artistique et le périscolaire
doit permettre à tout ce qui est plus
jeune j'ai entendu que maintenant voilà
faute de place dans les conservateurs
parisien cher philippe goujon on tire au
sort
alors franchement mais on est accablé
par ce que l'accès à la culture pour moi
c'est pas le fruit du hasard
et j'ajoute que dans plusieurs
conservatoires
on envisage de supprimer les cours
individuels pour ne pas privilégier les
plus doués alors là on marche sur la
tête de top non mais malheureusement on
on pourrait rire si ce n'était pas
dramatique parce que si vous voulez je
pense mais exactement le contraire c'est
à dire l'école fait partager l'émotion
même si on n'est pas du tout d'eau et on
peut aimer regarder on n'a pas besoin
d'être un futur réalisateur pour
apprécier un film quand même on n'a pas
besoin de ça va jouer un instrument de
musique pour aimer aller au concert mais
on n'a pas besoin de savoir écrire une
pièce de théâtre pour aimer aller au
théâtre mais si vous n'êtes pas dans une
famille qui vous y emmène ses l'école et
pour moi c'est très clair il peut pas y
avoir un seul département dans lequel il
pas d accord entre tous les lycées
tous les collèges et toutes les
institutions culturelles pour amener un
nouveau public
le public de demain dans les cinémas
dans les théâtres dans les salles de
concert et dans les musées
et justement les conservatoires ça doit
être des lieux d'excellence pour ceux
qui sont plus doués pour ceux qui
veulent aller plus loin et ça ne me
choque pas qu'on attache plus
d'importance
un futur génie que à celui qui est
manifestement aura beaucoup de mal à
s'échiner sur sur un instrument ou sur
une planche à dessin ce qui n'a aucun
sens et vous voyez qu à ce moment là
nous avons une cohérence entre la
mission de l'école la mission du
périscolaire avec les collectivités
florence la mission des conservatoires
et plus on s'éloigne plus on va qu'on se
concentrer sur un public qui va vouloir
sans doute faire du métier artistique
son avenir voilà j'ai été sans doute
beaucoup
beaucoup trop long et j'ai sans doute
oublié beaucoup de choses
ce qu'il faut que vous reteniez et merci
à tous les intervenants
c'est que pour nous c'est pas un
prétexte
le travail de ce matin j'aimerais
tellement vous convaincre de la
sincérité de notre démarche
j'aimerais tellement que le monde
culturel soit aussi sincère avec nous
que nous sommes disposés à l'être avec
lui mettant de côté les les images
mettant de côté les différences des uns
des autres
vous savez moi je ne suis pas un
président de la république qui est dit à
mon ministre de la culture flatte les il
aime ça je n'ai jamais vu quelque chose
d'aussi peu respectueux à l'endroit du
travail des artistes
et ce n'est pas parce que je vis avec
une artiste je pensais ça bien avant
c'est un travail exceptionnel c'est une
importance immense et vous savez vous
les artistes vous ne vous rendez pas
toujours compte mais quand on parle
d'une d'une époque d'une d'un temps on
se réfère un film à une musique un livre
beaucoup plus qu'à telle ou telle
décision politique
donc on n'est pas dans l'anecdote on
n'est pas dans la flatterie
on n'est pas dans l'utilisation cher
benoît donnons comme les uns à côté des
autres
nous on est content que tu sois là parce
qu'on t'aime parce que tu nous apportes
dont l'intelligence c'est pas pour m une
collection de nom sur un comité de
soutien ou pour dans un cocktail mondain
rassembler des gens qui se ressemblent
et qui se regarde dans le miroir
tellement il est mou il tellement ils
aiment leur image nous nous nous voulons
porter la politique culturelle du 21e
siècle
nous voulons porter un geste majeur et
pour cela nous avons besoin du monde
culturel
apportez-nous vos expériences
vous votre idéal votre volonté votre
ambition et doux on essaiera d'y
répondre aussi et c'est pour ça que avec
pierrick nous avons choisi une équipe de
qualité autour d'eux de david pour le
développer ce message culturel j'espère
que vous avez compris que pour nous
c'était pas un détail du tout c'était
essentiel et j'espère que personne ne
sache hockey que le président des
républicains n'est pas demandé
l'autorisation pour parler culture et
que vous ne l'ayez spontanément au fait
merci à tous